Привет! К этому моменту у нас уже есть компонентная база на реакте, каталог, по которому у нас все сверено с фигмой, все работает, песочницы и так далее. Это набор готовых компонентов, выстроенная база, на которой теперь мы можем строить экраны. Сегодня мы соберем целые страницы, как у нас в макетах собрано в фигме. Эти макеты у тебя уже есть, ты их собирал во втором модуле. Их и переносим в код с помощью директивы, как обычно.
Прежде чем начнем это делать, давай коротко, от чего зависит результат. Агент не рисует экран заново, он переносит в код твой макет и переносит как есть. Насколько аккуратно собран макет, настолько аккуратным и выйдет код.
Если фигма все на авто-лайаутах из компонентов твоей базы, то агент считывает эту структуру и собирает такой же гибкий экран. Он потом тянется по ширине, переносит блоки и ведет себя предсказуемо. Если макет накидан фреймами на глаз, отступы проставлены
руками компоненты, либо просто накиданы без авто-лайаута, то агент перенесет ровно это, только теперь в коде. Можно, конечно, просить его, прежде чем переносить, делать ревью, исходить из своей собственной логики при создании экранов, но здесь опять же, скорее всего, того же самого, что у тебя в макетах не получится.
Поэтому вывод, насколько собран твой макет, настолько хорошо собирается твой продукт.
При проверке курсовых работ я видел, что есть ребята, которые собирают на больших компонентных базах, например, на ShadyCN, о котором я уже упоминал,
и там эти компоненты отвязаны. Я вижу у ребят по курсовым, у тех, кто собирает на больших компонентных базах, уже готовых,
часто встречается, что на экранах в конечном итоге компоненты отвязаны. Возможно, что-то не подошло, что-то выглядит не так.
Лучше поправить в компонентной базе это, чтобы потом ничего не отвязывать. Если у тебя все отвязывается,
то здесь уже остается только надеяться, что по названию этого элемента агент соотнесет это с компонентом и соберет на нем.
Поэтому штука тонкая, тут нужно быть аккуратнее и запоминаем, что нам в первую очередь нужна системность.
Мы для этого и создавали ту же самую дизайн-систему, переносили ее полностью.
Есть компоненты, есть система, есть предсказуемый результат.
Итак, берем первую директиву, которая будет собирать экраны.
Сразу отмечу, что здесь мы придерживаемся статики, собираем только экраны без различных переходов и так далее.
Чуть позже я объясню почему. Закидываем его и говорим, собери все мои экраны, которые готовы в фигме.
И пока директива выполняется, пока он собирает экраны, отмечу еще одну важную вещь.
Это директива, это твой постоянный инструмент для сборки экранов.
Понадобился еще один, запускаешь ее снова, прикладываешь уже другой дизайн, ссылку на новый фрейм,
и она добавляет новую страницу в проект и подключает ее к остальным.
Один и тот же ход, но любой экран. То есть это не просто директива, которую ты запускаешь один раз,
она собирает то, что у тебя есть, и дальше непонятно, что с ней делать.
Можешь собирать новые экраны.
Я думаю, уже понятно, что к концу этого модуля будет еще одна курсовая,
в которой мы будем допиливать свой продукт до уже около финального состояния.
Поэтому вполне возможно, что ты захочешь собрать новые экраны, что-то добавить,
имей в виду, что также сможешь использовать эту директиву.
Итак, директива отработала, агент собрал все экраны, сразу вывел, какие именно,
и закинул нам на какую ссылку нужно перейти, чтобы на локалке посмотреть, как это все выглядит.
Он собрал сразу такую навигационную структуру со всеми экранами, которые уже собраны.
Вот у меня, например, есть дашборд, переходим, смотрим.
Пока переходов нет, нам это сейчас не нужно.
Также вот, например, создание сервера, как это все выглядит, уже сейчас можно посмотреть.
В целом, на самом деле, все совпадает с тем, что у меня в фигме.
Все максимально аккуратно, я на самом деле даже никаких правок делать не буду.
Ну и также сами модалки, например, их появление, все это сразу собрано,
все это работает уже, нам осталось только это нормально оживить.
Я попросил его собрать сразу все экраны.
Ты можешь делать по одному, аккуратно, постепенно, чтобы смотреть, действительно ли он все правильно собирает.
И тем самым не допустить, чтобы на следующем шаге что-то пошло не так.
Ну и в целом, здесь сейчас, если тебя что-то не устраивает, можешь написать ему, сказать, нет, давай поправим.
Тут как бы это без проблем все делается.
Ну и в целом, отсмотри все свои экраны, убедись, что он собрал все правильно и скажи ему, если что-то пошло не так.
Итак, смотри, мы сейчас собрали все экраны, пока между ними нет переходов, там особо нет анимации, только самые базовые ховеры на кнопки и так далее.
Почему мы сразу не собрали готовый прототип со всеми переходами и так далее?
Если у тебя много экранов, много компонентов, сложная структура, добавляются новые потом в дальнейшем экраны, контекст, который нужно держать в голове о переходах, о взаимосвязи экранов и всем остальном, он получается достаточно объемным в силу того, что еще и экраны нужно создавать.
И поэтому здесь что-то может теряться.
Поэтому, как я всегда говорю, если делаешь большую задачу, раздроби ее на маленькие.
Соответственно, и здесь мы сначала собрали все экраны, возможно, соберем еще какие-то новые и так далее.
А взаимосвязь между ними мы будем простраивать уже отдельной директивой.
Таким образом, в дальнейшем, когда ты будешь добавлять там какие-то новые экраны, вызовом этой директивы ты сможешь заставить агента проверить, а с чем он вообще может быть связан, куда стоит добавить переходы.
Если делать все за раз, то тут что-то может потеряться.
Делать это, оживлять мы будем уже в следующем уроке.
А пока давай поговорим о домашке.
Что нужно сделать?
Нужно собрать как минимум один экран.
Ну, желательно собрать все.
Скорее всего, у тебя там будет их около трех по условиям выполнения домашек во втором модуле.
Я думаю, что три это не так долго и собрать их можно.
Так или иначе, как минимум один экран у тебя должен быть.
Точно так же собираешь его с помощью директивы, агент запустит этот экран на своем локальном сервере, откроешь его и сделаешь скрин так, чтобы это было видно, что это ссылка в браузере.
Прикрепляешь этот скрин в Zen Class при сдаче домашки, и это даст нам понять, что у тебя все получилось.
На этом все. Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания и увидимся в следующем уроке.